vous allez
[Musique]
voir les
Parisiens achètent des baguettes ils
aiment le
vin et la chanson musette les Parisiens
traversent la rue
n'impimportout les Parisiens on les
rencontrere un peu partout à Paris sur
scène moi j'ai vu les bus et
Saint-Germain et j'ai descendu à la
prochaine au fond du
Métropolitain les
Parisiens se pressent au terrasse pour
regarder les Parisiens qui passent la
tour est fa il ne monte jamais
dessus mais
d'Espagne ils prétendent qu'ils ont tout
vu à Paris sur scène moi j'ai vu les
puces des saint-germains et j'ai
descendu à la prochaine au fond du
métropolitain et la ville
Silance pour regardarder la France du
mène à la défense Paris s'est mis
debout les
Parisiens dans les embouteillages on
dirait des
lions au volant de leur cage ils voudrai
en reconstruire Paris dans les
champs et alors tiens ce serait beau ce
serait grand à Paris sur scène moi j'ai
vu les puces et saint-gérmain et j'ai
descendu à la prochaine au fond du métro
politain et la ville s
lance pour regarder la
France m à la défense Paris s'est mis
debout les
[Musique]
Parisiens les
Parisiens